I don't even know what this name is I
think it's Hebrew I don't know uh can
you hear me do you have a microphone
yeah I have you hear me yeah
hey Rich how you doing good how are you
doing man can you see me I don't have my
camera no your camera's either off or
you got the cover on your lens I don't
know how to get it on but
good to be on the show I'm a long time
listener I read your book I read all the
rollo's five books um recently unplugged
like from Mark area okay and uh okay
what you might I have two questions
um what you might call uh unplugged beta
I'm trying to kill the beta and become
more Alpha and the name is Nick by the
way
yeah and I recently like two months ago
I dated a girl and I got out of the
relationship with two main questions the
first one is how do I maintain frame in
the relationship because I feel like I
only get bits of answers and there's
more to it I know I made a lot of
mistakes but I still feel like there's
stuff to be learned there so that's the
first question so like the whole thing
with frame in a relationship is it
starts from the very beginning
um she has to enter your frame she has
to be on board on your plan from the
get-go it's not something that you
modify later on down the road if you do
it right then you should be able to
maintain frame throughout the entire
relationship for those that are watching
that don't know what that is
in every relationship one person enters
the other person's frame he either
enters her frame or she enters his frame
what generally happens is early on women
enter his frame but as they
move forward and she has to talk and
does the whole Where Do We Stand sort of
conversation and he says fine let's be
boyfriend girlfriend and they start
dating and visiting family and they do
holidays together and dinners and all
that sort of stuff he he tends to go
through betaization through a thousand
concessions and then he starts to lose
frame so his frame is no longer the
dominant frame in the relationship so to
you sorry the thing is I I went in the
relationship with a frame with like a
relatively strong one and then I got
really
um confused when she started overtly
addressing subjects like a relationship
equality and you know I'm into I should
get to do this thing too and like she
starts overly talking about subjects
that are
complementary versus equality and I just
didn't know how to respond or react
you're gonna get that though dude like
you're gonna get most modern women today
where do you live by the way Israel Okay
so
I mean this happens everywhere in the
world you're going to get most modern
women today like I said put men through
betatization through a thousand
concessions it starts with basic stuff
like don't brush your teeth over there
you're going to get toothpaste on the
carpet or make sure you put your white
socks in the white hamper and your dark
socks in the dark hamper but then they
start pushing into other areas too right
like they'll start talking about
political opinions or start talking
about equality they'll start complaining
about things like why women get paid
less than men for doing the exact same
job and most guys will just start to let
that slide or they don't say anything
the thing that you got to remember about
frame is it's a thing that you have to
maintain right it's it's it's about your
only job and if you're able to deal with
those things as they come up and they're
small like you know when it starts with
don't brush your teeth over there you're
going to get toothpaste in the carpet
like I said you just kind of look over
your shoulder abuse Mastery and you
carry on doing what you're already doing
because it's your house or whatever you
know you've got cleaners that come and
clean anyway it doesn't matter but you
don't acknowledge these little [ __ ]
tests to try to get you to comply into
her frame she's not doing it
intentionally it's not like she gets you
know gets up in the morning Nick and
goes right I'm going to Beta ties this
guy I'm gonna make him my little [ __ ]
I'm going to make sure that I [ __ ] test
him and I'm gonna try to get him into my
frame they have no idea what they're
doing they just do it because they're
women right and they need to competency
test guys to make sure that you're the
best that they can get so as you're as
you start to get softer and you comply
more with her then you're going to enter
into a framework you're going to start
going to her events more you're going to
start agreeing to to buy things and
spend your financial resources on things
that are on her agenda you're going to
start moving your stuff into a man cave
and not have you know your house as your
Castle it's like you know then you hit
sequester to some dark corner of the
house and it's with each one of these
little concessions that a little bit of
your frame is given up and she takes it
from you okay so yeah I understand that
it wasn't so much concessions as it was
like discussions that I didn't know how
to exit or not to enter
talks about these subjects overtly yeah
so you just don't agree with her I don't
care I don't agree with you or like give
me an example you know so we can deal
with it that way to make it more
relevant too like an example okay like
and let me think
like when I told told her about my
not not in a particular example comes to
mind but it was always uh her she always
said like you know I should get to do
that too you know I would feel like
um I don't know like like stuff that I
did or said and she said you know women
women need to have that right too or
that kind of stuff and give me the
example of what the right is that she's
looking for that you have that she also
wants I don't remember it was like
specific moments in the relationship but
I got your overall point okay well well
let's use like this example then because
this is a common one that a few people
have probably heard already well if you
get to go out with your friends then I
want to get to go out with my friends to
the nightclubs and bars too okay well
men and women are different we have
different sexual strategies we have
different desires women are at risk you
know in certain areas of their lives
that men aren't at risk at like one of
the arguments that you can make is okay
well if you think that men and women are
equal the next time you hear a bang in
the night you get up out of bed and you
go downstairs and you deal with it and
I'll stay here right but they can't go
and you know like it's not an A La Carte
menu like I'm going to take this one
it's convenient for me but when I hear a
bang in the night or the window is
smashed then Nick has to go deal with it
because I'm the girl right yeah so
they can't have it on terms that they
feel comfortable with that work for them
you have to put your foot down and say
no it doesn't work that way and you have
to be okay with basically something like
a soft next to correct the behavior
which is something ideally that you do
before you guys start living together or
start running into these problems or
um
what's another way that you can deal
with it uh just a lot of guys like to
create drama right like there's this
there's this theme or there's this
notion that these women are
manufacturing drama in a relationship
because there's an absence of it so they
want to fight with you over something
like well if you do that then I want to
be able to do that too sort of thing
it's like no I don't date women that
behave that way well what do you mean
yeah I just told you exactly what I mean
I don't date women that behave that way
right and then you just leave the ball
in their court and if they carry on
trying to behave that way or they want
to continue to act that way then you
have to introduce consequences and that
might be breaking up with her it might
be a soft next there might be any number
of ways you know that you got to handle
it but I've said this many times guys
like dealing with women on a long-term
basis is going to be harder than just
spinning plates and just dating because
when they misbehave you can put your
foot down you've got other options you
can go off doing your own thing you can
hang out with your Bros she doesn't live
in your house she's not your girlfriend
you can do whatever you want women will
stress test the relationship when you're
in an LTR
frequently I mean they're called [ __ ]
tests and they're gonna do it and it's
going to be work for you to maintain
them and have them come back into your
frame in that relationship right it's
just a part of life right like look I'm
in an LTR
my girl should test me from time to time
I have to play these games too like hey
you know welcome to the world
yeah okay I had a second question this
was a quick one yeah and as I said
because I was unplugged and I saw all
the mistakes I did like but didn't know
how to handle most of them he eventually
probably smelled the beta and that's why
she broke up with me the thing is in
that moment I asked why and she said I
prefer to keep the reason to myself I
don't feel like I owe it to you and it's
the second time a girl breaks up with me
without telling me why and I wanted to
ask your opinion about getting the
reason out of her is she even gonna tell
me something useful like from the female
experience no she's probably gonna lie
to you anyway like when a guy breaks up
with a girl and they ask why they often
get that sort of response well I don't
owe it to you or it's in your business
right I want to talk to you the funny
thing is is that when a guy breaks up
with a girl she wants endless meetings
text messages emails coffees to sort of
reconcile all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's
going on her head and most guys give it
to them right so that's one of the big
differences you know between men and
women
all that all that you got to know is
that her genuine desire that she's had
from you has been removed and it's it's
generally going to be removed she
doesn't see you as boyfriend material
husband material whatever dating type of
material circumstances have changed and
it's generally because you've let
yourself
you let your frame go and you've and
you've handed her the keys to the
relationship men lead women follow it as
soon as Men start giving women the keys
to the relationship they start sitting
in the passenger seat of the car and
they let her drive sort of thing like
all of these minutians like all of these
tiny little areas where guys make these
small concessions add up over time and
then she eventually will develop some
sort of mindset like [ __ ] him I don't
owe him an answer or Dot and then she's
just gonna go and repeat the same cycle
with another guy over again and beta
ties some other dude and she's probably
gonna end up in the same spot so that so
there's little things that you can do
along the way like one of the things
that I just mentioned is when you drive
anywhere you make sure you drive the car
even if it's her car she sits in the
passenger seat when I go out if my
girlfriend's car is parked behind mine
and we have to take her car she doesn't
even think about sitting in the driver's
seat she's sitting in the car waiting
for me in the passenger seat I get in
the car I drive the car it's not even a
conversation right so these are things
that you that you establish early on in
the relationship you don't like it's
very very hard to get the frame back
later on in the relationship and you've
been dating for a while and you start to
handle the keys to things right like you
have to deal with it early on you have
to maintain it the weird part is we only
dated for like a month and a half and
she I was her first she was a 23 year
old virgin in the beginning and up until
the end she was madly like pleasing me
and cooking and pleasing me in the
bedroom and like four days before this
telephone call happened when she said I
don't owe you a reason for this prior to
that we still had great amazing all
night sex so it was really surprising
like how quickly she went from that to
that usually women that go from hot to
cold very very quickly they have
abandonment here it's it's um it's the
first I think it's the first red flag in
my book on 20 red flags let me just kind
of recap it because
I haven't gone through this he has all
all green flags like I didn't fight a
single red one well I can tell you right
now if she's going from hot to cold very
very quickly
um it's in the first red flag daddy
issues
no it's tied into borderline personality
disorder women that go from hot to cold
like if she goes from
extremely hot you know smoking hot sex
to like the next day I don't owe you
[ __ ] that's a bad sign that's that's
generally tied into BPD
it's
it's a flag I found she told me that
when she was very later her father
abused her her sister and her mother and
then the mother and the father got
divorced and during the 15 years since
then they repaired the relationship and
now she has a great relationship with
father I even met her father so it was
like a very tiny half red flag that I
you said that she didn't see her father
for 15 years no no I said in the 15
years after her
father and mother got divorced they
since repaired the relationship but she
grew up without a father
her father came around
yeah did you read my book I think you
said that you read it I read it yeah 20
red flags the first one is daddy issues
one of the things that's tied into daddy
issues is abandonment not having a
father in their life growing up for 15
years she didn't have a father growing
up she goes from hot and you know hot to
cold that's that's one of the telltale
signs of borderline personality disorder
I'm not saying that you know she had her
she didn't have it I'm not a clinical
guy that can diagnose it but what I'm
saying is if it walks like a duck and
quacks like a duck it's probably going
to be a duck right now
set that aside that that doesn't matter
probably the real reason why things went
sideways is again because like you you
know viewed your you know the
relationship and the way things went is
because you gave her the keys of the
relationship you know you entered her
frame but that was only a month and a
half that's a very short type of
relationship like that's really dating
that's not a relationship you know
generally speaking yeah it just fell
into a relationship status uh very
um she went very strategically about
this like four days in while we're
between rounds of sex she's like
harassing my dicks and ask can I tell
people I have a boyfriend now and I just
I made a mistake of telling yes they
just fell into it and that was a big
frame let the go probably on the get-go
how long how long were you dating before
she said can I tell people that I have a
boyfriend now
it was four days and we were in bed four
days yes yeah
you should probably read my book and
spend some more time yeah you're right
like you're you're you're describing the
characteristics and traits of a
unplugged beta mail
um a lot of guys that are new to what
I'm talking about unplugging from The
Matrix and getting these Concepts
squared away in their head it it's not
going to come through one pass in the
book it's not going to come from
watching you know like a few podcasts
it's going to come from some years of
work right like yeah I know I still like
even we still haven't created the
abundance mindset got it look like like
to sort of
help help you understand what's involved
here even me I wrote the book I am the
unplugged Alpha like I'm that guy I
still have to use like I still have to
pause from time to time and think to
myself
okay if I'm going to respond this way
that's going to look like [ __ ] so I need
to do it this way you know sort of thing
or if there's a conversation or there's
some sort of disagreement it doesn't
happen that often but when it does I
have to sort of course correct because
what we're all going to do is we're all
going to revert back to our plugged in
condition and we're all going to want to
plug back into the Matrix do what we've
been told to do our entire lives comply
happy wife happy life just be a nice guy
not our you know not our heads when they
start talking [ __ ] about how that's
not fair and if men can do it then women
should too because that's what we've
been told to do right so you have to
constantly remind yourself and one of
the best ways guys I'll tell you this
right now one of the best ways that you
can get good at this is do it while
you're dating do it while you're
spinning plates do it while you're
dealing with more women because you're
more often not just dealing with text
messaging back and forth make sure as
you're looking at the text thread that
she is in your frame you know she's not
telling you where you're gonna gonna go
on the date you're telling her where
we're going to go on the date and at
what time and if you like her in that
black dress that you saw in that one
picture you tell her to wear the black
dress because that's what a dominant
leader does and that's truthfully what
women want like they like they want to
enter your frame so it's a good practice
to start to get used to see what I'm
saying yeah it's really hard to kill the
beta but I want to thank you and really
roll too so much because I use so much
of the stuff in your books and I also
did a lot of things right in that
relationship which with like Dread game
and uh competition anxiety 23. oh you
got a long way to go don't worry about
chicks too much Chase excellence
yeah yeah I know thank you everybody
thank you for all you're doing thanks
man take care everybody hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out